[موسيقى]
خلال الليل يتظاهر الايرانيون امام بناء
البلديه في بوكان
خلال النهار يتظاهرون ايضا في احتجاجات
تخللتها اعمال شغب وكاله ايرن الرسميه
قالت ان مشاغبين دمروا ممتلكات عامه واحرق
بناء البلديه اما منظمه هنكاوي الحقوقيه
فقالت ان قوات الامن الايرانيه قتلت
متظاهرين في بكام الغضب ما زال يجتاح
الايرانيين التشييع في مكان تحول الى
مظاهره في سنندرج تحول 40 عده شبان الى
مظاهره كبيره هتف فيها المتظاهرون الموت
للديكتاتور تمديدا بالمرشدي الاعلى
للجمهوريه علي الخامنئي منظمته
قتل كما قتل عنصر من الامن وكاله ايرن
الرسميه قالت انه تعرض لعده طعنات ادت الى
مقتلته قوه الامن اطلقت الغازه المسيله
للدموع على المحتاجين في المظاهره الاخرى
وخرجت مظاهراته في جيلان وفي شيراز ومشهد
حيث تقول وكاله ايرنا ان عنصرين من
البنسيج قتل طعمه واصيب دون خلال
محاولاتهم التدخل لان مشاغبين هددوا
التجار لاغلاق متاجرن وزير الخارجيه
الايراني عبد الله اللهيان اتهم في تغريد
اسرائيل واجهزه استخبارات غربيه بالتخطيط
لحرب اهليه في ايران في مقال رئيس الحرس
الثوري في قم انما يحدث في ايران مؤامره
دوليه